hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone for so many questions for my
Doctor Who Q&A and thank you for
submitting comments about what I've gone
going on here I just turned my camera
around just cuz I thought this looks
more interesting than the white
background I'm working on sound proofing
too so you won't hear that
echoey sound in a little while here are
a few quick additional notes from the
episode before we get to answers first
off commenter John Ellis pointed out
that the cave where the Mary men hid out
was also the place they filmed Sherlock
Hound of Baskerville that episode it was
called dewers Hollow and I know a lot of
you have wondered about Capaldi's sonic
they were seen filming on set with the
Matt Smith sonic in future episodes so
apparently he didn't permanently lose it
I guess he just went back at some point
and they just chose not to show that and
I do address the deleted scene during
the Q&A but here we go on to questions
careful for spoilers from episode 3 if
you haven't seen it yet I'll wait just a
sec ok everybody ready here we go
question number 1 Kevin GX is the
Promised Land Gallifrey I definitely
think that Gallifrey missy's heaven in
the Promised Land are all connected even
if there are all different places we
know that Gallifrey is in the pocket
universe and we know that Missy is the
gatekeeper of the nethersphere we don't
know what that is yet but because of all
the dead people she's saving it's
implied that she might have Time Lord
like abilities after I saw a deep breath
after that first episode I thought that
the promised land might be a metaphor
unique to each person like the clockwork
droids idea the Promised Land was
something created by his own mind and
the doctor's idea of the promised land
was Gallifrey I don't think the robots
in episode 3 or the clockwork droids
we're trying to get to Gallifrey though
otherwise that screen would have just
read Gallifrey instead of saying
Promised Land
I think that the droids were responding
to some sort of summons you know
sinister or not sinister whether or not
it was a trap I think that that's what
Missy is doing like she's calling people
to the promised land it's starting to
seem like everyone has the same reason
for wanting to find it on to question
number 2 Hydra de little asks Earth has
a twin planet called Montes what did
that's where the promised land image was
so that's a good theory in Cybermen are
supposedly supposed to play a big role
in series 8 so it's totally possible
that
Mondas could be back just like Gallifrey
came back there have been a lot of
spoilery images of the finale that adds
some fuel to that fire but since a lot
of you request that I not use those in
my videos I'll just allow you guys on
your own to search google if you want to
find those I am starting to think though
that regardless of where it is the
promised land is a Missy trap of sorts
maybe not a trap for the doctor but a
trap for everyone else it would sync up
with the idea of Robin Hood entering the
archery contest knowing full well it was
a trap the interesting thing about that
though is that Mark Gatiss said that he
specifically wrote this episode to not
fit within the Missy plot so any
connection would be coincidental
even though Mycroft technically doesn't
believe in coincidences - question
number three big and wide asks there
have been a lot of reports of a lot of
familiar filming locations from the
place chameleon was killed by the fifth
doctor as well as the fires of Pompeii
with a lot of similar images the
all-time with the idea of the doctor
leaving himself subconscious messages
what are some theories about how this is
going to be explained so right now it
seems like all these common images have
to do with the doctor playing God
altering timelines when it suits him
choosing who he saves who dies usually
you leave yourselves reminders when you
want to remember to take an action so
I'm hoping that the next villain miss
del Fox and the futuristic bank give us
some more clues we've only seen a few
episodes so I'm not expecting a lot of
theories to pan out but it's possible
the doctor is trying to remind himself
to do something instead of not do
something that episode that miss del Fox
is in is number 5 it's called time heist
so that's in two weeks but on to
question number 4 Matt DASCO asks which
historical character do you want the
doctor to meet next so I'm really
looking forward to the mummy on the
Orient Express episode foxes in that I
don't think she's playing a historical
character but I am gonna keep my eyes
peeled for some characters from Egyptian
mythology on to question number 5
Holly kids Lee asks do you like the
faster pace of the episode so far this
episode felt like it was meant to be
more of a reflection on Capaldi's
journey so far yes I really do love
Capaldi's pacing I think he created this
really unique Malcolm Tucker character
so it's a lot easier for him to bring
that kind of crazy energy to scenes but
it's still also a lot of fun to see him
slow things down
and take a look at what's going on like
with the Apple in the sonic just
reflecting on himself I think we will
see a lot more of that you know episodes
were Capaldi is thinking about himself a
lot more and not just barreling through
scenes watching these new episodes also
kind of makes the old classic episode
seem really trippy just because
television in general was much more
about long dialogue back then you know
long drawn-out parlor scenes and now you
just see a lot more jump cutting and
explosions that's probably just a meta
commentary on people's attention spans
nowadays but on to question number six
Joey
asks how do you feel about the BBC
cutting the beheading scene did you want
to see it so I actually think it was
totally appropriate like the reason they
did it was completely justified I didn't
watch the leaked episode so I didn't
even really know what the scene was
until I read about it later since then
it seems like it presents the sheriff as
a half-man half-robot and yes I
mentioned Mark Gatiss didn't
specifically write robot of Sherwood to
fit inside the Missy plot but it's
possible that the half-man half-robot
thing was foreshadowing for Cybermen I'm
totally fine not seeing it if it were
something that was critical to us
understanding the plot of series 8 the
BBC would just post it online so people
could find it if they needed to on to
question number 7 the new view
production asks Rachel the director of
the finale it said to count the number
of planets in the opening titles is
there a hint about Missy in this so I
truncated your question it was super
long and super amazing but yes I
actually found the picture that she
posted or the tweet so she posted this
really recently and for reference she
directed both the final two episodes
that's a two-parter but they're airing
them one week apart so they're not gonna
air back-to-back most of what I read
about this focuses more on the big
planets that we can see really well not
these background tiny ones the best
theories are that this is Gallifrey or
it's post-war trenzalore
the other planets could be moons and
Gallifrey did have two moons supposedly
they were destroyed during the time war
but because of the 50th they could be
back with Gallifrey after thinking a
little bit more about the trenzalore
theory I do like the idea that it
suggests Capaldi really is the
fulfillment of the silents prophecy
about that first question
and remember Capaldi has been asking a
lot of questions it's just one more
thing to add to the theory pile but just
as a reminder going forward as we get
more info
about Missy and the promised land think
about the planets in the title sequence
and how they all might be connected to
her and Capaldi question number eight
michelle Saloni asks this episode
reminded me of the classic who episode
where the doctor met all the fairy tale
characters which episode was that so
you're thinking of mine robber from the
second doctor's run I don't know if Mark
Gatiss intended to make specific
references to this episode it might just
be coincidence but the fairy tale
characters in the old classic episode
call the doctor a traitor because they
view him as a fairy tale character who
just rebelled Robin Hood speech at the
end of this week's episode was all about
the thought that it doesn't matter
whether or not the story is real just
that the story serves is a call to
action for people reading it it's really
nice meta commentary on the power of
fiction to inspire people part of me
actually wants to think that Missy is
someone inspired by the doctor story and
is doing what she believes to be great
work in his name like saving people for
him I think about Missy is being a crazy
fan of the doctor with crazy power but
on to question number 9 Paul calorie
knee asks what do you think about the
idea of Madame de Pompadour being Missy
the robots were more advanced versions
of the clockwork Troi so it's possible
that Missy has Madame de Pompadour brain
that's definitely an interesting way to
think about her Madame de Pompadour
could still be holding on to her idea of
the doctor as her boyfriend of sorts and
if her brain survives in a very advanced
robot body
she could have become a little bit
twisted over time as cool as that would
be I'm actually kind of hoping that
Missy turns out to be a completely new
character I have a feeling that if she
turned out to be a classic old character
no matter what the explanation was most
people would wind up disappointed fan
theories like the ones we talk about
here are always gonna be way more
complicated and way more interesting
than what the actual reality is I like
the idea that Missy is someone from the
doctor's past but someone that the show
has never done before I think it just
gives Moffat and Future showrunners more
material to work with I feel like people
would get tired of Doctor Who a lot
faster if they just kept recycling old
things over and over I know there's a
joke about the Daleks in there somewhere
but you get the idea and question number
10 last one
Trent MacIntyre asks do you think that
when Moffat leaves will see the master
again so I took this more as you asking
you know what will future showrunners
bring back
that Moffat has avoided there's
definitely things that he said he's not
touching because either Russell Davies
just did them or things that he didn't
want to do because he felt like he had
nothing to add to the material I think
of all the things that he hasn't done
future show runners will just pick up on
really open-ended threads from the most
interesting classic episodes like
stories that focus more on characters
that already haven't been done again and
again during new who since Davies just
did the master I'm not expecting to see
him again
until the 10th anniversary of new who at
least I don't even know if they're gonna
do an episode for that you know there is
this crazy possibility that Missy could
be a female master or a mistress but I'm
guessing she's gonna be someone else
that 10th anniversary of new who is
March 26 2015
it's basically the anniversary of the
first episode of new who since the
Christmas special is the next big
special that we know about I don't know
that the BBC is producing any special
content for that March date but
hopefully by the series 8 finale we'll
know whether or not we're gonna get some
exclusive content I do think the BBC
will celebrate the anniversary in some
way but they might not produce a full
episode for it but thank you so much for
so many questions these are always a ton
of fun to do especially since series 8
has so many fun things to theory craft
my next bonus video is gonna be for my
favorite scary Doctor Who episodes just
because listen looks like it's gonna be
a pretty scary episode like family of
blood I'll try to post that before
episode for air so be sure to subscribe
to get it
and congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Carmen Chan you win an
Amazon gift card I'll message you on
your channel for details
as usual the next round of the giveaway
will start whenever I post my episode
for review but in the meantime click
here to get my episode 3 review and
click here to get my top 10 favorite
historical characters thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you